the W unit tells the browser the
dimensions of an image file so it can
make a sensible choice about which image
to retrieve but what if the image isn't
displayed at a hundred percent width of
the viewport
well the browser parses the HTML and
starts image pre loading before the CSS
is passed and at that point it knows
nothing about image display sizes here's
where the sizes attribute comes into
play the sizes attribute tells the
browser the sizes at which an image will
be displayed so while parsing the HTML
the browser can work out which image
file to request in theory the browser
could get this data from CSS but CSS
parsing comes later adding the sizes
values to HTML ensures the browser can
fetch images as soon as possible the
right image for the right image display
size and device capabilities just to be
clear the sizes attribute does not
actually resize your image you still
need to do that in CSS okay remember our
source set example for W units
well let's resize our wallaby now she's
50% of viewport width let's take a look
at the network request for that you'll
see that even at the smaller window size
the browser is still getting the medium
image which is larger than you need so
let's work it out the window is 400
pixels wide so the image will be
displayed at half that width 200 pixels
wide we're on a 2x display so we need an
image at least 400 pixels wide to look
okay now our small image which is 500
pixels wide should be fine got that okay
so at the time the browser fetches the
image it doesn't know anything about the
display size of the image so it defaults
to assuming the image will be the full
width of the viewport so let's add a
sizes attribute reload and see what
happens the small image is downloaded
the sizes attribute here is telling the
browser this wallaby will always be
displayed at 50% viewport widths and
given the files available please
choose appropriately what if you want
different image display sizes at
different viewport sizes
well the sizes attribute really comes
into a tone with media queries that
wallaby was getting a bit too big so
let's put a limit on the width now in
this example we've set our wallaby to
display at a hundred percent viewport
width at viewport widths of 250 pixels
and less and 50% viewport width above
that notice how's the sizes attribute
corresponds to the CSS just to reiterate
the sizes attribute tells the browser at
HTML past time what the image display
width will be it doesn't actually affect
the display size of the image and by the
way I've added a CSS transition so the
size change isn't too jarring just
because I felt like it you can get the
actual source chosen for an image using
the images current source property make
the window bigger and tada you can see
that the image has a different source